join us now to discuss the Fallout at
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger good morning Jill how you
doing I'm well now we broke it down a
little bit but I want your thoughts on
it what's going on here and could this
happen to other Banks well you know as
Errol just described there was this very
strange event that occurred last week
and it was a slow-moving crisis because
if you look back say 18 months ago we
saw the tech sector booming and one of
the banks that did tons of a business
with the tech sector was in fact Silicon
Valley Bank so as those companies
started to do really well what did they
do they deposit more money at the bank
the banks flush with cash they keep what
they think is enough money on hand to
meet General depositors increase and
needs right and the rest of it they
start to invest in United States
government bonds at the time interest
rates were so low that the bank decided
they would choose a longer maturity now
that's great you get a more a higher
interest rate but the downside is when
interest rates start to move those
longer dated bonds are more susceptible
to price declines what happened last
year the FED started raising rates the
value of the bonds went down as these
tech companies needed more and more cash
all of a sudden Silicon Valley Bank had
to sell their bonds at a loss and that
put them in a terrible situation I would
say that this is essentially went from a
cash crunch to a full-blown run on that
spank so last time we've seen something
like this a failure like this was that
of Washington Mutual back in 08 what
will be the ripple effect of it now in
2023 well I think that Janet Yellen as
part of the team that really did focus
in the financial crisis understood that
we needed to get ahead of any potential
Ripple effects that's why they announced
those emergency measures I want to point
out something that's very different
between 2008 and now number one this is
an idiosyncratic situation a bank that
does business with startups Tech crypto
is different than all the banks being
involved in the mortgage business the
other thing that's important when we did
the bailout back in 2008 we bailed out
the companies their shareholders and
management the government is not doing
that they're protecting the depositors
but remember shareholders and management
they're out they've lost all their money
in the in this company the FED said U.S
banking is resilient is it though I
think it really is they've done a much
better job in making sure that big Banks
the largest most significantly important
financial institutions are sifis gcipes
the big the global ones they have to
have more money on hand but as Errol
mentioned when you've watered down
regulations when you tailor the
regulations to help small and
medium-sized Banks this is the flip side
of that and it is dangerous
thanks brother appreciate you